sin más que se extienden hasta donde
alcanza la vista La cordillera Blanca es
una imponente cadena montañosa en el
corazón de los Andes un paraíso para los
alpinistas europeos y un lugar popular
entre los turistas cada año 30.000
personas viajan para conocer estos
paisajes
como el glaciar de pastoruri a 5.200
metros de altura es maravilloso te deja
sin aliento ver este glaciares como
estar en otro mundo
pero tras el paisaje de postal hay una
realidad preocupante en diez años ya no
habrá este nevado se va a desaparecer la
desgraciación está muy acelerada por el
cambio climático hace 20 años yo venía
aquí con mi familia y este era una una
pista de esquí en 2013 las agencias de
turismo peruanas propusieron que se
hiciera esta excursión para sensibilizar
a Los visitantes frente a las
consecuencias del cambio climático no me
esperaba para nada ver algo así ver el
glaciar derretirse delante de mis ojos
es muy triste el Instituto Nacional de
glaciología de Perú sigue de cerca el
deshielo de los glaciares a 50
kilómetros del glaciar de pastoruri este
equipo de científicos estudia el lago de
palcacocha considerado una amenaza en 50
años su volumen se ha multiplicado por
34 hay glaciares inestables que pueden
generar avalancha y de hecho puede un
desborde al caer en la laguna y eso
puede generar un aluvión que puede
afectar a la ciudad de huaraz el cambio
climático responsable por el deshielo de
los glaciares aumenta el riesgo de
catástrofe en el peor de los escenarios
el lago se desbordaría y millones de
metros cúbicos de agua caerían sobre
huaraz y sus 120.000 habitantes puede
llegar unos
30-40 minutos a la ciudad de huaraz por
eso es necesario esta Laguna tiene un
sistema de alerta temprana según Los
investigadores una inundación de gran
magnitud afectaría a más de 45.000
habitantes en huaraz tal como se ve en
el mapa de riesgos elaborado por el
instituto de glaciología más del 50%
corresponde a muy alto y alto todo lo
que corresponde a rojo a rojo y
anaranjado van a ser destruidos o
parcialmente destruidos y van a ser
inevitables Saúl Luciano es dueño de una
casa en una de esas zonas de riesgo por
ahora existen al pie del Lago Saúl pide
que se construya una tercera Barrera de
protección la obra costaría unos 4
millones de dólares para Saúl el
gobierno regional no debería correr con
todos los gastos los científicos están
diciendo están demostrando que
que las Industrias están contaminando y
la consecuencia es el calentamiento
global el cambio climático con la ayuda
de la ong
decidió denunciar a Art whee productor
Alemán de Electricidad la empresa no
opera en Perú pero German watch ha
señalado que es responsable por el 0,5%
de las emisiones globales de CO2 desde
el comienzo de la era Industrial ese
porcentaje es calculado no el casi el 20
mil dólares y esa cantidad la empresa
tiene que poner para la construcción de
un deck para la protección para reducir
riesgos los jueces del tribunal Alemán
de ham viajaron en 2022 a Perú para
investigar y deberán anunciar su
decisión el próximo otoño para proteger
la ciudad las autoridades locales le
apuestan a la prevención Cada año los
estudiantes de huaraz salen a las calles
Con un objetivo informar sobre los
reflejos que pueden salvar la vida en
caso de desastre este prevenir este y
estar alerta para este tipo de desastres
que se pueda presentar en cualquier
momento no la la naturaleza no avisa da
un poco de miedo ya que tal vez tú no
estás tan prevenido otras personas no
están prevenidas pero
ahí puedes morir perder familiares seres
queridos por ejemplo Aquí estás ahorita
tranquilo en tu casa y empieza a temblar
y tienes que tener y estar prevenido
preparar tus cosas para una ocasión así
no en la región ya han ocurrido dramas
similares aquí todo el mundo conoce la
tragedia del 31 de mayo de 1970 ese día
la ciudad de yungay quedó completamente
sepultada por una avalancha provocada
por un terremoto en 5 minutos Javier que
en esa época tenía 22 años vio su ciudad
desaparecer bajo 53 millones de metros
cúbicos de roca hielo y tierra cubrió
toda la ciudad no quedó una sola casa en
pie de la antigua ciudad de los 18 a
20.000 habitantes que solo quedamos 480
personas vivas sus padres y sus abuelos
no sobrevivieron el balance total 50.000
muertos Javier había salido de paseo con
unos amigos y se salvó al subirse a una
colina nos cubrimos la cabeza esperando
que lo que pase levantamos la mirada
vimos que no había nada de la ciudad un
trauma anclado en la memoria de la
población que cada año conmemora el
episodio con una ceremonia en este Valle
sometido a los peligros de la naturaleza
el deshielo de los glaciares genera una
nueva amenaza actualmente en la
Cordillera Blanca se monitorean unos 50
lagos glaciares peligrosos
[Música]